did we do it
hey i think we did it
t aurora hello
ryan morrison hello
hello everybody
it's been such a long time since i've
been live i kind of forgot how but we
got it
awesome hello hello hello hello
everybody hello
i messed it up
hello everybody
mr anderson
best mod in the world's back
y'all better watch out for him
hello everyone
it is good to see everybody
oh if mr anders started cracking down on
the rules
hello how's everybody been
hopefully everybody has been good
just making sure i got all my stuff
right looks like i do looks like the
sound's okay
everything's sounding all right
oh hello from south korea
hello sue from south korea it's a it's a
decent time for you right now
for being here right now appreciate it
uh i have watched the first episode of
arcane uh fantico the first episode i
i'm so behind on it
i've uh
i've been pretty busy very behind on it
so
hello from australia jasba
like that name interesting name
is it kind of confirmed for the trailer
i mean they're gonna do something like
my said in my video today they're
they're
they're uh
they're gonna do something whether it's
you know
a
big trailer or teaser
or
a tv spot that's the word i was looking
for
or uh i i'm actually thinking like
footage unlike uh
good morning america or something like
that would uh
be pretty cool
ah you're welcome sue
i don't have anybody to speak korean
with so my korean is like
very rusty and very bad
like little korean
can't really do it
[Laughter]
hello alejandro cruz hello hello hello
hello how is everybody
oh i see some mephisto's there
kevin feig even holding the sniper
how long until it comes out i would say
about
20 minutes
new zealand
reagan super hello hello hello hello
everybody love to see everybody here so
good to have everybody
back uh it's been a while now we have
six episodes of hawkeye we got she-hulk
miss marvel got a lot coming hey d nasty
nelson's back glad to have you back bud
glad to have you back
please shout out oklahoma i'm actually
an o-u fan i'm not sure if that's the
oklahoma you wanted
apologize if it's not but that's where
my dad was born and uh raised for a
decent amount of time and he went to ou
for college and so did my grandpa so
uh
jorge not sure if that's the oklahoma
you wanted
uh yeah
bradley jones from kannapolis what is up
kernopolis i'm still thinking we see
that and uh ant-man and the wasp so i'm
still thinking that we've seen that
we've seen chronopolis i think that
could be inside the city
but uh good to see everybody back good
to see everybody back
how has everybody been are we ready for
spider-man new way home i'm sure uh
yeah okay everything i see with the
kingpin and i've already done my
breakdown because i've seen the first
two episodes
and i'm thinking kingpin's the main
villain of all of this
uh there's not really any big like
spoilers for it
but like if you've read the comments
comics
you'll
you can kind of know like
you'll you'll see hello to everybody
from india yash yadav hello hello hello
i know mr anders i know it just wrapped
i'm uh
i'm surprised we didn't get
as many like photos like we didn't
really get much from it but i think
kevin feige's got uh
his snipers hanging outside of all the
sets you know what i mean
yeah yeah i see some people talking
about spider-man no at home and jay
might uh
and
mj might die i you know i don't know
i don't know i don't know
um do i think hawkeye is unnecessary
and waste of time just like black widow
ah no
no um
is it my favorite show no but i
but hawkeye's not my favorite avenger i
know a lot of people do have hawkeye as
like a favorite avenger and i think that
if you really like hawkeye you're really
gonna like the show i think if you're a
really big fan of kate bishop or haley
steinfeld you're really gonna like the
show so i think it just kind of depends
um
yeah it's gonna be different for
everybody i like my my friend tessa from
mama's geeky she loved the show
loved it where i kind of set it in the
like
i don't i don't want to say i don't want
to like dampen the mood for anybody but
my friend tessa loved it i know a lot of
people who loved it
uh um just it just depends
hey or hey that was the same oklahoma
man i used to have an ou chair now i
have a tony stark chair but i have an ou
chair downstairs that i used to uh
that i used to sit in boomer sooners
there we go
peter dies in no way home i don't think
so and i am thinking that
i am thinking that um
he's going to continue because he's been
talking like he's not going to continue
but i believe he is
uh
your boy brandon
yeah
if you love haley stanford you're going
to like this
um
do i play minecraft sid hunt some rotten
new york i do it's been probably about a
month since i played it
we're gonna see a hawk biting clint so
that he can become hop guy and manga
does that's pretty funny oh no no hold
on i saw super chat hey what's your top
three audience in terms of countries uh
one is usa two i believe is india and
three is
somewhere in england i think
i think that's what it
is uh
actually whoops i took this away here
i need to
go here
supers here we go
t nasty nelson c toby and zuzia at the
same restaurant yesterday
is that old
are these old i don't
sorry guys look at some super chats here
to make sure i didn't miss any are these
old super chats
why doesn't it give me a time stamp okay
here we go yeah yeah here we go
t nasty nelson i missed one from you i
apologize see tobian's day at the same
restaurant yesterday yeah um
guys to me there's so much
evidence
of uh toby and andrew
uh being in the film and hey if you
don't
you know if you don't believe it if
you're not buying it no big deal
uh i do think you'll be wrong but i
don't mean that in like a haha you're
wrong type of way i just i've i'll tell
you guys the same thing that i've been
that i've been saying
i do have connections i do have contacts
and
i have a contact who
has seen the movie
apparently
and
he's pretty much told me everything or
she
and
they're in the movie that's
like all i could say because like i've
just been told by so many contacts that
have given me like accurate information
in the past that has come true and
they've all told me like yep they're in
the movie
karen singh
mon korea
i'm sorry i know i didn't pronounce it
right i'm so sorry
well how could be worth your time
you know i've only seen the first two
episodes so i actually can't say i think
there's
a lot of potential for it to really be
worth our time then um i miss the watch
parties too hey thanks so much glad to
see everybody back um
have i seen cws aero yes um
not recently though
disclosure not recently but i do like
the show it's a good it's a good show
probably
probably one of the definitely one of
the best to come from dc
what's up louis doco
yoyoyo
we are live but the episode is not out
yet jared
warren what if the removed figures next
to peter and doc and regardless the dead
of two peters i could explain why you
know what that would be cool
um
but i do think it uh
it's it's
i do think it's um
the other two spider-man because green
goblin's supposed to be
the the main villain of the movie
green goblin's supposed to be making
villain movement
avinash rimal i do think kingpin is the
villain of this and you all will see why
i'll connect it for you guys in my
breakdown um dhruv argawal i do remember
you welcome back
welcome back everybody
do i know
kanto
no i don't know what that is
well i go to the no way home premiere
this is something that people have been
asking me a lot and my answer um
right now is i don't know because it's
like i've already been told by marvel
like it's completely sony like it's all
sony marvel isn't in charge of the like
the press tour so i'm not going to get
any interviews marvel isn't charge of
the red carpet premiere anything like
that even pre-screenings like i'm
actually probably going to be watching
it like when you all watch it so
um
i don't know anyone at sony it's the
problem uh i'm making contacts now
and
i've already made one contact and he
said that he wasn't he doesn't have
anything to do with the event
this time so he couldn't really do
anything he he called some people
to ask about it and
he said that um
it was like a dead end um but i'm gonna
talk to him at the first of this month
so maybe
maybe i can get into the premiere um
i also have a few other contacts that
might be able to get me in um but also
at the same time i've heard that sony is
being like
really weird about the premiere like
they haven't given
like where exactly it's at yet they
haven't given all the stuff yet so
i'm not sure who they're inviting
like for venom it wasn't like a big
premiere and they did like a bunch of
small ones like venom let's be carnage
and i was at the one in l.a at the imax
headquarters but it wasn't a premiere
like the big red carpet so i don't know
what they're going to do
as of right now i'm not going to the
premiere but i i'm trying to talk to the
right people
teenacy nelson strange that warner
brothers mentioned past couple times
batman superman scooby-doo dc marvel
crossover i mean i just i pray right i
mean
can you imagine like i would
i would love it so much like that that
would be just the
sickest thing you know what i mean like
oh
what's up lake gaming how's it going
uh somebody asked and i do apologize i'm
looking for the comment now i don't
i don't see it i'm gonna
um
maria laura pellegrino i do think matt
murdock is the dinner guest actually i
just recently saw talked to daniel rpk
about that
um
i wouldn't expect them at the premiere
uh
dang it i'm really looking for that
comment um
hey warren how was your time with real
rejects and new rockstars eric foss oh
it was fantastic leon uh i mean i talked
to greg i talked to greg like four times
today from the real rejects we we talk
all the time he's one of my best friends
um and i keep a close circle so that
says a lot about greg he's a really
great guy john's awesome eric is uh
incredibly humble
just a really great guy um i love new
rockstar i love philip over there um
they're all just good people like and
they're the best at what they do they're
better than my channel i'll admit it
i've never argued that fact um
they're just so they're just so great at
what they do there
okay spidey 1925 what would be your
opinion if toby ninja not in the movie
um i would be
the
biggest missed opportunity ever
um
and i don't see how
i don't see how they would
get a get away with not doing it in all
honesty like
how are you gonna have a movie where
from what we've already seen how are you
gonna have a movie where you bring back
doc ock
okay let me be more specific alfred
molina's doc awk from the sam ram
universe william the froze green goblin
from the sam raimi universe sandman sam
raimi universe
electro lizard amazing spider-man
universe like
how are you going to get away with
bringing all these people back them
referencing spider-man you're not peter
oh you think your new suit's going to
help you like this is all referencing
toby maguire spider-man how are you
going to get away with bringing those
people back but not bringing the other
spider-man on screen how is that going
to happen like
people will riot their building i mean i
hope not right i mean but fans will be
so upset
so upset
hey matthew jennings me and new
rockstars yeah they're they're fantastic
and i uh appreciate that comment yeah
brooks gunn biggest health they aren't
again i've been told they are by by like
good credible sources i obviously can't
mention them by name but
yeah how do the spiderman enter the
movie i i would tell you
but i don't want that big of a spoiler
but it's with a sling ring is what i'll
say
well okay i mean they come in through
like the same universal way that the
villains come in
how do we see them for the first time
sling ring
which spider-man movie do i like the
most it's gotta be just spider-man toby
maguire original spider-man it's
because i i don't know how i'm 32 i'm
old
depending on how old you guys are um
i was uh you know
i was like the prime age i was like 12
years old
it was like the perfect age to watch
spider-man i was like just this kid who
was like all hung up on spider-man and
the x-men at the time like
and and that that's just that was me man
like
it was a dream come true the x-men movie
came out and then spider-man i was like
on cloud nine it was because all i
watched in saturday mornings was
spider-man and the x-men show like
that's all i did and i read the comments
and it was like
it was so cool it's such a cool time so
spider-man so the first x-men film and
spider-man are always going to have and
the fantastic four are always going to
have a good place in my heart because
they're like the first superhero like
on-screen live-action films that i ever
saw
which mcu spider-man suit is my favorite
i mean i really like the iron spider
suit um
i wouldn't say it's my favorite but
i'm thinking of all the suits in my mind
i mean
we're gonna
for kind of the new movie i actually
really like the golden black one which
is just the the red and black one
flipped inside out
i think that one's pretty cool
siobhan
please tell that the no home final
trailer would drop or not and big fan
thank you so much um
and to
ramy
where'd it go
um i don't i if it's gonna drop it's
gonna drop on what they're calling
spider-man day
november 29th
i missed a comment those in chinese i
can't read chinese so it's irrelevant
but
i was gonna maybe type it in the
translator and see what happened
guys if you spam
mr anderson he's gonna kick you
uh
he's gonna he's gonna kick you so i'd
watch it
he means business
there's black widow flashbacks you know
one part of uh
of this movie
is the fact that
hawkeye is gonna kind of be dealing with
some stuff
right um he's going to be kind of
dealing with some stuff how many
episodes did i see of hawkeye i saw
somebody asked wow the chat's really
moving now sorry hold on
oh
i'm so sorry i cannot find that comment
but uh or how many episodes have i seen
i've only seen two
um
dixie marshall how are you causing
wonder i'm good what superhero that has
been introduced mc would you want to
play and that hasn't been introduced
would you want to play um i would love
to play adam warlock but they just cast
will poulter
besides that uh wolverine
i'm only five foot seven
five eight on a good day um i'm a really
bulky guy like i got muscle but i'm also
kind of chubby
so i could lean out to play wolverine in
a heartbeat in a heartbeat um
feige if you're watching
i got you and i have act i have an
acting background as well so
hit me up hit me up
we should all twitter
on twitter
warren plays wolverine i don't know some
stupid fight
hollywood breakdowns
my first live stream with you due to
time problems ah well i appreciate you
being here welcome welcome welcome
uh shang chi a good avenger heck yeah
all right let's uh let's do a little
refresh here because sometimes they uh
they always go early um
disney plus refresh
uh miso corny nice name are any of the
spiderman going to appear in multiverse
of madness thanks for that super chat
you know
there was ramblings about that before
that they were but i haven't heard
anything recently about that like set in
stone so i'm not sure
uh
david chacon thank you so much do you
think toby maguire will die in no way
home if so would you be surprised yes i
would be surprised and i think this
would be a huge mistake if they did that
i think they should give him a happy
ending the same with andrew thanks for
that super chat maj d
how did the spider-man engine be oh i
already talked about that sling ring all
right let's uh
oh i was watching shang qi while i was
waiting to go live let's see what we got
here
i'm not seeing it yet let me type it in
come on update
where's the search
up there hawkeye
collection coming soon
oh they're out let's uh let's start this
let's start this all right everybody get
ready get your uh computers ready
pulling the chat over here
mr anderson will have the time we are
starting in three
two
one ago
why is this
all the way down here whatever
oh you know what dang they did they
switched it
i can't show
man i can't show any footage anymore
guys
because they like updated the disney
plus settings you see this it's just a
black screen right here they updated the
disney plus settings to where
dang they updated the disney plus
settings to where
we can't show anything anymore let me
see
what's my stream look like all right
here we go this is the coolest opening
scene
this is such a cool opening scene
dang i wish i could show you guys i'm
sorry i can't it's literally just a
blank screen
i wonder if i like go at it
nah it's just a blank screen frick
dang
all right well we're watching it
i wonder if i could time stamp this now
can you hear the audio
uh
how much did you hear i mean you can
hear the audio here but without the
without the picture it's it's nothing
because i can't even show the picture
they're blocking it that's uh that's
kind of crazy
all right we're watching it
protect you love it
this is such a cool scene right here
this is such a cool part right here
this is such a cool word
mr anderson i blocked the word pj so i
think i might have stopped it
it's 2012 that means the avengers are
fighting people in new york right now
guys i wish i could show the show but
it's not popping up they got some they
figured out how to block it now
i could play audio a little bit
it's kate bishop as a little girl during
the battle of new york
so this part's so cool right here
don't hurt her
this part's so cool this part's such a
cool part right here
that part right there that's part sick
that part's so cool
yeah they figured it out ma'am
i'm sorry it's not like it's not plant
look i have it pulled up like i'm
literally watching it
they they figured out how to block it
that's a problem for me because i have
to be able to screenshot it to do my
breakdown this is going to kind of suck
i don't know how to
we'll have to figure that out
this parts that was such a cool part
though i love that part
thank you then come again
come back ken thank you so much love
back to india
trey elgato you mean el gato because
that's actually what i use
see what's weird here is there's a
tombstone in the back that i think says
russell russell bishop
and russell bishop was like this guy who
murdered two girls
nothing related to comics just a guy in
real life and murdered two girls which i
thought like was weird and her father's
name is derek bishop not
not russell so i thought it was like
this one's really cool this is like the
matte fraction run it's like the same
exact illustrations
and the hawkeye show is based off of the
matte fraction run but
like
very loosely based off of the matte
fraction like very loosely based off of
it
subs pewdiepie i got some my g fuel oh i
thought this was pewdiepie g field it's
regular g fuel
episode one and two yes we got uh
we got both we got both today
the steam testing my mic seems good guys
yeah i uh
you know what let me try something real
fast what if i did it on chrome would it
show on chrome
i wonder if it would show on chrome
how are you not advertising hot guys out
dang it doesn't even show that
oh it briefly shifting that's a bummer
sorry guys they
they figured out how to how to block it
thank you jay dog i appreciate that guys
if you search for it on disney plus
search hawkeye it'll pop up you gotta
search it it won't just pop up disney
won't like upload it or refresh it that
fast you gotta you gotta search for it
right now we're watching kate bishop
about to shoot a tennis ball at a bell
tower
opera gx browser
interesting i'll have to check that out
i'll have to download i don't want to
download it right now my
my stream's kind of
going a little bit
and bang
yeah chris is ahead of me by like a
minute and 10 seconds
my youtube for creating the channel was
i love
marvel
i love super heroes
i like talking about them and one day i
guess people decided they wanted to
listen
[Music]
you're in trouble
and that's a kate bishop in trouble
uh we are watching at 11
55 right now that's where we're at 11
55.
let warren play wolverine there we go
jim
jump joseph appreciate that
yeah i'm waiting for you linda versus
clint too
i haven't seen it in the first two
episodes so
oops
oh the musical
the musical
hawkeye is not having the musical
i can do this all day
[Laughter]
i don't think it's that bad
i mean it is a musical
oh he's he's having a
yes kyle i am mephisto
he uh
uh he's having like he sees nat and he's
having you know
but not withdrawals but like ptsd for
nat
so sad
hey thanks
jayward i am over in shishant
i know what happened i was there you
know it wasn't there ant-man i don't
know why they put amber in the musical
i
so clant's daughter lyla is played by
ava russo who's the daughter of joe
russo of the russo brothers
smash smash smash
i'm not sure i would be able to uh
i'm not sure i'd be able to sit through
this musical like i probably could just
because i'm a big marvel fan
i can do this all
all right we're we're getting into the
energy drink level of the
oh yeah
we're getting to the g fuel part of the
stream
now we're only in the first episode and
we're only 14 minutes in 34 episodes to
go
do i think marvel is promoting female
characters very much um
i think they kind of did it well in the
beginning and i think they're doing even
more now they're doing a good job
oh my gosh
g fuel
use code cosmetic
there's a bogo right now
dude if someone walked up to me when i
was peeing in a urinal and walked right
up to me and asked for a selfie
that'd be weird
to be super super weird
um
i know right next to him right next to
him put drag
this
fire fox do it
but isn't firefox
window does [ __ ] meet kate before the
second episode end yes in fact they are
together pretty much the entire second
episode
dude i know mr anderson it's like the
weirdest thing like if somebody came up
to me and did that i'd be so upset to be
so pissed
it's so annoying that i can't show you
guys a little like literally it's just
coming up black like i'm watching it
right here like look
i'm watching it right here on my screen
but it's not showing up it's just black
it's just a black screen
what did we do
that works
i don't know if that's where it worked
before it's not it's crazy though
uh robocop or terminator more
probably terminator but it's been a
while since i've seen robocop
uh no way home is set in christmas ryan
we will see some snow
you've been both
um
hawkeye takes place two years
after avengers in game
two play two years after vincent game
i mean i could i guess i could try to
show you guys just like little bits and
pieces like that hey william thanks for
super chat
i think we'll see a scene in spider-man
where matt merrick listens to peter hart
to see like telling [ __ ] uh i
i hope so i think he might just kind of
realize he's telling the truth though
i hear he catches a brick out of nowhere
and it's like i'm a good lawyer
all right now she's just talking to her
mom
that's all we got right now
and then we see a sword in there and
she's like what the heck's up with the
sword
jack
what an unexpected surprise all
surprises are unexpected that reminds me
of
that's a made up word oh words are made
up
hey
spidey
sometimes you got to do what you got to
do
one spotting 1925.
cheesy gentlemen i'm not sure i've heard
rumors but nothing like legitimate that
they'll return
a big christmas tree in new york
stay hydrated kids
it was a show
well
have you seen swordsman in the comics
because that's his mustache
big old mustache like that
that's a bummer i can't show it geez
gingerbread house
christmas movie marathon
stay hydrated stay cool there you go
a mustache
just jinxed it you can't say it's gonna
be the best barton christmas ever like
and that just like automatically jinxes
it
so like i wonder how old it gets like
when people
like when you're a superhero like
hawkeye or
like iron man or steve rogers when they
were alive or like the whole bruce
banner
um
you know
like when you go
when you just go out in public and
people just like offer to pay for all
your food and like
you know when your meals are free and
stuff i wonder like does it get old or
do you just accept it and i would just
accept it i mean
i'm always for a female
so they actually switch up this
character from the comics from the
comics this character is actually jack's
father but
he's not here
i feel like that kid's from something
but i can't remember what he's from
a little bit of a chat yeah
for those of you who can't watch it
we're not really uh
not really missing anything right now
the beans are out of the bag
um i've ever met tyrone magnus now i've
never met tyrone magnus but we're like
cool because you know he racks my videos
and stuff and
he knows the real rejects very well and
greg alba from real rejects is one of my
best friends so
uh it's out yes just search hawkeye and
disney plus
they're all they're doing right now is a
family stuff you know hawkeye and kate
bishop i haven't even met yet so for
those who can't see it right now and
we're not really missing anything
guess what we're gonna see
guess what we're gonna see
is lucky the pizza dog the one-eyed
pizza dog
that's gonna be fun
is there
no wm connection in hawkeye
what is wya i'm like spacing it
i love lucky to be i'm so glad they
brought look at the beads of dog in this
such a good decision by them
everything seems to be going good with
the streams too
and why are you
snooping why would you ever like just
she's like come back to the party okay
but she doesn't go with her and then
it's like i'd be like come on like i
know you're just gonna go look at the
thing again like come on
i really wish that
i really wish
that i could show this man like
it's so crazy how
they block it like
dang
them
oh i just noticed that that person said
gary wants you to bring these down
oh
that makes sense for uh
first thing that comes later
hmm
um i haven't seen a spiderman no way
home connection yet but i haven't i've
only seen the first two episodes
so this part is cool this this this part
right here i'm gonna i talk about this
in my breakdown so be sure to watch the
breakdown
uh episodes are out we are watching it
right now i just unfortunately
can't show it because it's uh being
blocked some magical mysterious way
so they don't get along
very ugly
it's a right not a rhinoceros a
triceratops
two million
hey look it's the real rejects
while prepping the vid
well prepping what bed
you watching me while prepping the vid
thank you
i'm sorry i cannot pronounce that but
thank you
oh no all of a sudden the real rejects
take over the shadow okay i see
this is for home display only
you have no idea where you got it
ah
working on the thumbs why am i not
getting text messages to go over the
thumbnails
what is happening
in total how many minutes ah
40
two
yeah
it's like 45 minutes
but both episodes are like 45 minutes
long
look what sword it is it's the ronin
sword
no i can see the
i can see it guys it just won't show on
my computer it's just completely black
like
see it's playing right now see it's
we're going oh you can see the pictures
here
look at that that's interesting
that's interesting but
but besides that it's not showing
i i freaking hope kingpin's gonna show
up i really think it would make sense
but we'll see
uh
i'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
right now all that's really happening is
there's an auction underground
and she's snooping around
and there's the sword that's up for
auction belongs to ronan see the sword
and that's her mom's fiance so that's
like her stepdad
and the sword gets sold
why did the
lighting just change there we go
and now they're selling the suit
but now people just kind of
people broke in
and there's a big explosion underneath
and everyone's kind of got hurt
as they were auctioning off the ronin
suit
so everyone's kind of hurt right here
and i don't want to get my freaking
channel taken down so we're gonna
we're gonna avoid showing too much
why does the lighting get adjusted every
time it's so weird
there we go
cool
i should really put my scarlet witch
poster i should pull it down more
there's a big explosion right here
yeah i'm not going to show too much of
that guys because i'm going to get
i'm going to get who just busted through
the wall you're about to see
notice what they're wearing notice what
the villains are wearing and you'll uh
you'll figure it out
see the track suits that's a giveaway
uh
i'm gonna give you a hint elena is not
in either of these episodes
okay bishop has taken the ronin suit and
put it on
uh can i give away some disney plus
subscriptions yeah that could be a good
giveaway
oh great god bless texting me look at
that
um
amethyst
short for them no because it's not their
movie you know it's tom's movie
smash smash smash smash smash
is us agent going to show up in this i
doubt it
i'm actually wondering if elena will
even show up in this
yes i am excited for midnight gamer
extension free fire
fight fight fight fight
that was a lucky mistake
but he's got a gun
what's interesting is they weren't even
looking for ronin they're looking for
some watch
oh big punch big punch big punch
greetings back to coke costa rica uh
who is my favorite marvel character
of all time that's a tough one
probably wolverine though
the watch from the avengers compound get
him lucky get him
don't kick lucky
don't kick lucky
i love lucky
pal right in the kisser
kick to the face
i don't know about miles morales but i
definitely there's a big chance kingpin
is the uh is the bad guy here
she saved him
look at this this is like the dumbest
thing let me just take my mask off
rule 101 you never take your mask off
you never take your mask off
why would you take your mask off
the tree is pretty cool if anybody's
ever in new york during christmas time
and you get to see the uh the big old
christmas tree in
times square
maybe the rockefeller center i think
where it's at i don't remember exactly
where it's at but it's pretty dang cool
it's really big
mr anderson is a person
and then just saved a dog but it's not a
ninja it's ronin and that pisses hawkeye
off and makes him worry
slice to the head
ronin
uh never meet your heroes is just like a
saying that people say it's never meet
your heroes because they'll oftentimes
disappoint you they'll not like be what
you expect them to be because like
like in your head
like okay like
if i could meet like probably anyone
like i would ask to meet either like
taylor swift the members of blackpink
the members of twice or itsy um but it's
like i have my idea of what they're like
in my mind and when i meet them they're
probably not going to be like that right
because i don't i don't know these
persons at all so
they'll probably disappoint me when i
meet them because they're not how i
thought they were so that's kind of like
you know that's kind of like
what that means don't meet your heroes
because they'll probably disappoint you
because they're not going to live up to
whatever you think they are in their
head right
like i've met a lot of celebrities who
are douchebags and it's kind of like oh
that's sad like i remember uh one time
i
i
went to a concert and i met the lead
singer of one of my i won't say who but
one of my at the time favorite bands
and he was a douchebag and from then on
out i was like oh man like
you were so cool to me before and
like in my mind like you're so cool
you're the lead singer of this band that
i really really enjoyed really like your
music really like your lyrics but your
douchebag so i don't really like the
band anymore and i i stopped listening
to them so
that's what never meet your heroes means
uh
i don't know if aaron davis could appear
i i think they're gonna really keep it
focused on hawkeye and kate bishop
that's why i'm not even sure if you
elena's gonna show up
douchebag warren 2021 yeah
uh daredevil netflix was not canon to
the mcu but look at that
that's a no-no
yeah i drink water right from the jug
right from the drug
my pc is a jet if you're referring to
like the the noise that's that's an
actual fan that i have on me because my
pc gets hot
i didn't realize it was that loud
thanks louis appreciate that love back
to you
yeah ricky
ricky 246 that that happens you know
it's like you meet these famous people
you think they're gonna be so cool and
then they're douchebags
don't meet your heroes
uh-oh tracksuit mafia
yo she's got some sick moves you gotta
give her that like she's got some killer
moves
uh gamer extinction i i don't know about
that
rtx 390 no i don't have the rtx 390 i
actually don't really know what i have i
cuz i built this pc such a long time ago
i can't even remember it's like two
years old
it's time for a new pc in all honesty
i just need more capacity on it
it's perfectly fine it runs everything i
can game and stream at the same time but
who is this hooded figure i wonder
i have a page in imdb
didn't know that maybe i knew that
oh someone's got her i wonder who it is
i'll show this part
he just realized who it was
and he goes come on
and she goes you're hawkeye
and he goes who the hell are you and
that's the end of the first episode
and then we get christmas music
uh michael's keaton's vulture can be
back in nowhere home yes
and no way home nowhere home
far from home where home no way home
there we go all right that was episode
one
uh how do i go back
i am going to be getting a timer on here
so because
man i'm so bummed that i can't show it
to you guys i really uh
i really am bummed uh
i'm sorry uh this isn't gonna be like
normal street off the
i'll have to figure it out
how i did it before
so
that's a bummer all right are we
ready to go
actually hold on can i do this
how do i there we go
cool all right we're gonna start this
second one
is everybody ready
are we good to go
uh i do not play forza horizon 5 but i
do race cars in real life actually
um all right guys
we're about to go
we're about to start it so let's do it
in
five seas or episode two and five
four
three
two
one started
let me get this timer on here
oh my gosh come on streamlabs work with
me here
there we go
now i have to watch it on this screen
though
wait if i move this over here yeah it
shows it i'm just gonna put the chat
right here
i do race in real life right now i have
i have two cars that i race one is just
for on the strip uh mercedes amg e63 s
and i have a bmw m4 competition mode
which is what i race on the track
young people think they're invincible
and rich people think they're invincible
and you have always been both
i wish i was both i wish i was young and
i wish i was rich
so
hollywood breakdowns
youtube streamer you have to use an obs
to stream
unless they change that but it's always
been you have to use
some type of obs to stream
so i use streamlabs as my obs
michael keaton's vulture does have a
chance to return in no way home but i
think we're we're more likely going to
see him in morbius
[Music]
top three mcu movies um
hey thanks gabriel yeah that was like
the first
like
you know it took me four years of doing
youtube before i bought like something
really nice that was like the first
thing that like
i was like i'm finally doing okay in
life
and uh
i can uh i could buy something nice for
myself and that was first thing i was
like i really want a mercedes amg that's
what i got uh i am 32 easy lord i am 32
years old and my top
three mcu movies gotta be thor ragnarok
uh shangching legend of the ten rings in
the first avengers film i don't count in
game and if anywhere they're just way
too good and on another level to to
really consider
they're above it
all right so hawkeye realizes that ronin
going around is just a kid and not
actually some dude trying to be ronin
i wonder if i
no
no
no that doesn't work
because if i
dang it you still can't see it
i still can't see it
are you assessing threats she's just
trying to learn she wants to learn
i i think hawkeye's worth watching but
i've only seen two episodes so like
i don't know how it ends
i can't tell anything about past first
two episodes first two episodes pretty
good though
are you one of those people
she's starstruck i mean i would be too
if you met
like you know you're like if iron man
all them were real and you met one of
them you'd be like it's lucky the pizza
dog
and i inherited it
give me back the ronin suit
uh captain america soldier yeah it's a
great movie it's in my top ten but uh
doesn't take my top three
all the trophies
what did you do in the suit i beat some
guys up
he's not wrong 18 and 22 are
pretty much the same thing one can drink
the other can't
oh for sure ryan no way home's gonna
freaking
can you sign this
ah you're my favorite avenger
track suit mafia
um
no i've never met the canadian lad but
we have
talked online
uh no i haven't done mcu tier list yet
i'm doing a watch party because
everybody else gets to watch it for the
first time and i want to talk about it
after with everybody
hey kate bishop
my name's on the buzzer
these guys the attraction mafia cracks
me up because they're like
they're dumb they're like dumb
uh the sound quality of these courses
are better they are more expensive but
chris from cosmic culture
he has a cat and he got in my office one
day and chewed through my headset
so i got these in return they are better
and they're also wireless they're
plugged in right now to charge but
they're wireless as well
these poor guys and like the freaking
the pizzeria sub place like their place
is getting wrecked and it's like
um yeah i'll show you a bit
it's not really an ex
like this current parts not really that
exciting so
it's just a track suit mafia
kate and i'm trying to
it's clinton hawkeye together
she says oh we're gonna get avengers
supplies but they just go to like the
pharmacy for a little bit
you know what if i'm gonna show it i
might as well make it a little bit
smaller so i don't get in trouble here
lucky the pizza dog though a little
lucky boy she just has the bow like just
walking around in the freaking store
all right
can't tony sold that
all right i gotta turn it back for a bit
don't want to get a copy strike don't
want to get in trouble don't want to
piss off disney all of the above
a bag of money would be useful to me
i'm not sure how many total views the no
way home second trailer had
you just go to the youtube channel
take a look on youtube and then take a
look at twitter and
yeah mr anderson right totally normal to
just carry a boat around
uh yup hawkeye episode 102 r out we are
watching it right now
i think fisk is going to return possibly
in this show
i know i'm miss jenner right mr anderson
they just showed people like ways to
like
get into apartments
going back to get the suit and then back
to the kids
don't you need my keys nope i'm freaking
hakka i know how to get into things
yeah i don't think juan is going to be
in uh no way home guys and thank you
rafae
appreciate that
oh thoruca welcome home from school
have i met any of the actors actresses
from the marvel movies yes i've met a
lot of them actually
i met a lot of premieres
so sometimes at premieres you meet
actors really really quickly and you
don't have time to take pictures and
stuff because they're like moving along
and the security is like pushing you so
i bet seema liu
at the shang chi premiere
um i met
uh
manger zahn who plays his sister uh
follow chen and i interviewed her of
course as well uh i met liam mchugh of
the eternals it was right next to
angelina jolie i met taika watiti
i've met a lot of i met a lot of them at
some premieres and stuff yeah
hawkeye just takes the freaking fire
fighter suit
like it's nothing the guy just knows how
to
how to do things
and
that's when he sees it
nyc larpers wait till you see what
larpers are um
if you don't know what they are i didn't
know what they were
spotty 1925 that's funny john cena chad
city
you can't see me time's down
hello hassam thanks so much for the love
hope you're doing all right
no i don't i guys the person who punched
a lizard it's got to be toby or andrew
here's where we kind of get like the
banter between them
between uh
okay bishop and hakka
thawing out pizza dogs perfect they
literally call them pizza dog
earl of sandwich
you did it all wrong
hmm
uh in this episode no they're not i've
i've seen this episode i know they're
not going to show them in this episode
thank you huzzaifa khan appreciate that
well it's almost 2 30 a.m here that's uh
yeah
uh no they probably won't change
directors for eternals too i think they
liked what chloe's out there chloe's
opted
yeah that's uh
it's light here
has my
opinion changed about the internals
maximus santos no i still consider it
like a seven slash eight out of ten
i really liked it
it wasn't a masterpiece but i really
liked it
see ya gabriel thanks for stopping by
thanks for all the
oh no
that's uh jose bach de toro saying good
night good night
good night jose
thank you we will have fun thanks for
stopping by
hey the kraken life's pretty good you
know
can't complain
hope you guys are doing good
you're a good dog ah
lucky the pizza dog
hey we just changed the name to lucky
pizza dog in the chat look at that
cooper's in charge
he's an idiot why is he in charge
guys i'm tired
it's a good thing i've done
my breakdown already hello sad i hope
you are not sad right now
i see you're still here uh
gabriel
sign language
i could have been the caretaker dang it
kurt missed opportunity for me
i'm tired
i promise you i'll be home for christmas
that's the that's gonna be like the
whole thing of the show now is like i
have to get home i promised my kids i'd
be home for christmas uh no i don't
think there's gonna be homecoming for i
think it'll start over like maybe it's
like a new uh
trilogy
um
but i don't think it'll be like a
homecoming one
hey
ninja07 thanks so much really appreciate
it
maybe season two yeah
um
i don't know yeah it's pg-13 probably
because like violence and stuff i
haven't heard him cuss or anything yet
the ronin
has the ronin returned
less than 24 hours you've been on the
news twice
the tracks are dead woof
i'm pretty sure i say it in every video
except for like my interviews
she owns a security company
ah thank you sad appreciate that
i want to but no
uh kurt man
i don't know if elena's gonna be in this
i really don't they might be saving that
for like a movie granted i've only seen
the first two episodes but
we'll see
because i want to hear you but i need to
hear you
look here's where you find out where
he's like kind of hard of hearing
all the explosions oh this part's kind
of sad mommy a superhero
looks real
nope that's katniss everdeen
um from what i heard vietnam is going to
appear in the post-credits scenes
see if that's true
that said a cool cool thing
but you do anyways
inspiration
you're selling inspiration
oh god i'm getting tired
yeah i'm not sure it's gonna be the last
time you guys see each other
trick errors
uh info on world breaker hulk mod um
not really much more than i did in the
video that i released on it um
there's not really much known about it
right now
yes kurt i am secretly the sixth villain
don't tell anybody
guys i i actually can't play hawkeye
it's um
it's not showing up i have it on disney
plus here but like they updated
the app and
somehow it's
they've blocked it
sorry for your loss i found this dead
body i mean i saw it on the news
very big shot
it's not it's definitely not my aunt
because i definitely was not um
hiding out
to rate venom let there be carnage out
of 10 i'd probably give it like a six in
all honesty
i thought it was okay
shh don't tell people that i'm the sixth
villain
dude if i was her agent as step dad or
future stepdad that was like telling me
that stuff i'd be like
yeah you gone bro
i come up with the camera
hey jax how am i doing
pretty good tired
but uh favorite mcu character right now
would have to be thor
i love thor or lucky the pizza dog
i would like the mcu dude in mcu to have
miles morales yes i would
after peter parker
thank you orange love right back at you
this is funny
live action role play
hey
hey thanks cheesy i do the best i can
sometimes the streams get pretty crazy
and it's hard to reply to everybody but
i try
uh sweetie pie forever i'm not sure
that's a good question
i think i do think they're going to
explore some of the relationship with
natasha because they are going to
explore this past so
maybe but i wouldn't count on it thanks
or what's up malek
i'm pretty sure like the biggest dog is
the golden retriever
so i'll show you guys a bit in just a
bit because it's pretty funny
so basically like right now what's
happening
i gotta be able to see this is uh he's
signing up for this live action role
play stuff
because he's trying to get the suit from
this guy
and he's like aw
crap
your armor your armor
so he's about to go in it i'll show you
guys in just a second
all right
this part's pretty good so he's like
going in and he's like but all
begrudgingly like you know
i should probably again not put it oh no
i stopped it
but it big screen but he's going in and
he's got a
he's gotta go find the guy that has a
suit and all these people are gonna
start attacking him it's kind of funny
[Laughter]
so basically he just goes in and just
whoops everybody like just whoops
everybody and i'll show you guys a scene
in just a second but
i can't shed too much hurts
and then i get copyrighted
unfortunately
does neil yell at me and that's not
something i want
he is sad about having to do this mr oh
my gosh goodness
it's just
so he find
so he finally gets to the guy
aren't you hawkeye
i can take this pretend sword and you
pretend to die i take that suit or i'm
gonna real punch you
and you're gonna real fall down and then
i'm gonna take the suit
just let me kill you
i'll give you the suit
no
[Laughter]
you're a superhero in real life this is
close i'm gonna get let me kill you
please in the game
[Laughter]
because i [ __ ] thanos
and i fought thanos
no no no i can't just
it's funny how he's like let me kill you
but
gotta make a spectacle of it right it's
really funny
is it night in my country yeah it's a
208 am it's very late
hello
i'm uh
ima i think that's how you say that
it was pretty funny how dwayne
no spam of viral a v-roll but hello
welcome
excuse me
let me kill is the closest i'll get to
government dragging me down for killing
an avenger
here's the guy from fortnite oh gosh i
can't tell you how many times i've
cringed at that
now they're gonna say that about
they're gonna say that about freaking
naruto
rick and mort so much
hi greg if you're still here
he didn't drink the potion
all right this part is pretty funny all
right guys i'll show you this part so
it's like the part where they're
fighting hawkeyes like the guy's like
let me kill you dang it
the guy's clinging it
oh wait
what is happening
you gotta make it real they got to
believe it
got to make it real they got to believe
it
you ready
kill me
[Laughter]
he goes i fought thanos
because uh
we burned the corpse now
uh maximus wolverine
you can call me clint i can call you
clint
no they they will charge you
this guy would have a great narrating
voice nice deep low voice
you had fun
glad i did it
i'm grillz
i hope grylls comes back
he's awesome
come on just let me kill you it's the
closest i'll ever get you're a real
superhero just give me this uh
that's so funny that's so good
talking to the wifey
chris evans might be back in captain
america 4 for a little cameo or some
hey mephisto welcome to the chat i think
it's edited out i think green goblin is
the ultimate main villain of the movie
i promised lyle i'd be there for
christmas and this is where
that's where like the timing of it all
he has to get home
before christmas all right i don't think
there is a six villain guys i think it's
just five sony has a project they're
gonna do
for the sinister six
so i think they're avoiding putting six
in here
one of nat's old moves
time to get myself caught one of nat's
old moves i love that
can you imagine being that rich like
what the heck
i can't i can't fathom that
i really can't fathom that like
oh i forgot about this scene
i assure you i'm not too good to be true
the offense
i dabble
i'll show you guys the scene in a bit
it's pretty cool
you know your stuff little lady
fertile ground for bonding
what a
weird way to talk
uh you can book tickets for no way home
kanishk uh november 29th
uh thank you lewis but my name is warren
w-a-r-r-e-n not warden but thank you
it'll be fun all right
he's going to get his stuff
because he because she heard that he
fences
so this seems kind of cool about to flip
it around all right
it's a little fencing scene between
kate bishop and uh
and her
soon-to-be
stepfather
and she tags him and he's like wow
you're good
and she's like don't let me win i'm not
holding you know don't hold back and
he's like i wouldn't do that
but then they go again
all right
give me two seconds and i'll show it
again
this is like inception
oh that's not what i meant to do
can we just work with me computer thank
you
so she's like stop letting me win
and he's like come on you're a two-time
state champ
and she goes at him horde
and then okay
what are you hiding jack
and he's like nothing i'm an open book
but he's not looking and then she swings
and he's like
guess what i'm better than you
he says i downplayed my skill
i'm gonna go change
nah she was they weren't training she
was uh
she was straight up testing him
so
jack his name is jack but in the comics
it's jacques jacques which is french i
think that's how
you say it and he is the
villain anti-hero swordsman
who is an expert swordsman so that's
this is his kind of comic origin coming
into play
hello jose um spider-man vs kingman i
actually think
that
kingpin is going to be in this series
uh no kurt it won't go to netflix it's
gonna go to disney plus
like we've always planned that's like
how some parents are hey thanks zaber i
appreciate that
hey akash yeah i've heard about sandra
bullock and she denied anything with
marvel um we'll see though everybody
always denies it
sorry for scaring you into telling the
truth
i think tom hall will return fives
uh kurt i do believe that they're going
to by this point in time yeah i think
that's going to happen
oh the butterscotch
the butterscotch from armand's place but
i think it's too obvious i don't think
he could have killed him i think it's
that's just too obvious
killer mustache bro killer mustache
uh my yonk that would be pretty cool if
he was an alternate cap
all right so hawkeye is getting captured
intentionally here
are some of you guys done watching it
already we're not done watching it i
think we got like five minutes left
yeah we have like
five minutes left
yeah
i have a
i should try again
i don't think tom cruise gonna be the
new iron man no
maybe a cameo
i agree with him enough we need lucky
more in the mcu
that tracking software is so cool
it'd be like a boyfriend or a
girlfriend's worst nightmare though
your boyfriend girlfriend or your wife
or hasn't been able to track you
even if you're like trying to get them
like a
like a christmas gift or something
wicked wicked bro
yeah it's pretty cool charles
jaden uh i don't know maybe at the very
end of spider-man
no way home
but i don't know it might be done for a
little bit
this is episode two or
you're not hawkeye well okay
i guess i am
hey thanks lehigh appreciate that
sue it does kind
of give you natasha verbs right
came here to talk to your boss who's the
boss
joshua alvarez i about like not don't
have to bruh
i haven't had to ever do that
and
there's kate bishop
bro
bro i found her it's like
these guys are so dumb
bro i found her
who's the boss
who's the boss i know the bosses
don't talk
it's echo
bro bro yeah lewis right
they are walking cliches aren't they
lacking l-y okay i don't know how to say
that uh who's my pick for wolverine me i
wanna play wolverine i'm never gonna
stop
putting that out there all right
all right
that's uh that's the first one
all remember this dude okay streamlabs
work with me thank you okay
that's the first one there's no post
credits or anything like that let's get
discord open um
i don't need this anymore brian slick uh
man you know i i kind of said this in my
like spoiler free review
it's gonna be for some people it's not
gonna be some people if you don't like
it i
i get it if you like it i get it you
know what i mean it's um
maybe it'll it'll pick up at the pacing
in a bit i think kingpin is the villain
um
i i really do i really do think king
ping is the villain here
hold on
that's a crest that's a chris
my question is
can people
talk
hello i think people can hear you now we
just gotta
how do i make you big there we go
there we go
there we go
nope
nope i gotta switch it hold on
all you have to do is deactivate your
camera on streamlabs and put yourself in
discord
and then i can have it
[Music]
how do i deactivate it just hit it off
just go to the tab go to properties
deactivate
i think can i reactivate easily
yeah
where i don't even know there we go okay
hold on fam i got you
wait here's chris
um
i don't see deactivate is it under
something
just click on
the camera on your streamlabs and hit
deactivate under property hit property
then hit properties okay
hello
hi can you hear me oh i can hear you now
how do i get my camera
you go to discord
so now you're there so just make your
whole stream you can see me
yeah i don't i don't know how well
that's going to work
that's how i do it and it works very
well
for some reason
it's not working
hello everybody i'm back
maybe i'm almost back give me a second
i'm back okay
eat
all right so hawkeye all right guys
i already see some in the chat put put
what you put what you think in the chat
down below what did you guys think of
hawkeye chris what'd you think of
hawkeye
can you hear me uh we lost chris oh
there we go um
i think just like with every
i'm gonna fix my screen
um
[Music]
um just like every show that starts it's
very boring at first and people struggle
to necessarily and
get into it there's no hype behind it
you don't know what you're expecting i
love the show i think the show's gonna
be fun
but for a while i think you know you got
to build that hype
that's my honest thoughts
well
i think this is going to be a show
that's going to have a big division with
fans like even more so than the
internals
i think some people are gonna hate it
and i think some people are really
really gonna like it like my buddy greg
at the real rejects
really thought i was just kind of
mediocre and then my friend tessa mama's
geekies thought it was like the best
thing ever she called it pure perfection
i don't know about that
but that's the deal is i think i think i
think
i think it's gonna be a pretty big
division
i think i really do
um
i
i don't know what to expect because i
think kingpin is behind everything
that's what i think i
and and i'm waiting to see
what's
really happening because echo's not bad
echoes a good person and she's going to
go on to get her own series so it's like
all right what's the real deal here
right you know people have to decide
whether or not they want to get behind
those villains right i think there are
people who care about kingpin but i like
you saying there's going to be a
division i think there are people who
just don't well kingpin is not even
guaranteed to command right i mean
exactly but
when you look at loki or wanda vision
and we're sitting here trying to guess
who's the bad guy behind it all i think
a large amount of that excitement
is the villains that we were guessing
generated at excitement yeah and i don't
know how many people
really are honestly excited about
kingpin
or any other villain you could generate
for this
i think i think people would get excited
for kingpin for sure um i really do uh
one second bradley jones thanks for
super chat never at the comics kind of
just learned what characters watching
films have been said can you explain who
echo is what she does well she's deaf
and that's a big thing so
echo's story is
her father was actually killed by
kingpin
as her father's dying and she watches
her father die
um as she's dying she tells kingpin
it's it's really weird
kingpin kills her dad but as he's dying
he's like take care of my daughter raise
her right and so he does
but she kind of doesn't really realize
that kingpin killed her dad right she
just kind of saw him die
um so she works for him then she goes on
to he's like oh i need you to like
seduce matt murdock but she actually
does fall in love with him and then he's
like i need you to take out daredevil
and she doesn't know matt murdock is
daredevil
and she almost kills him but then
realizes that
it's matt
her love and uh he kind of tells her the
truth of everything and then
she actually shoots him in the face and
causes him to go blind
uh
fisk that is uh kingpin so like
he eventually gets the sight back but
you know she's good she turns good so
i'm like waiting for
i'm waiting for kingpin to be behind
everything uh jordan lane
i love how throughout the past few years
we keep seeing different angles of the
battle of new york thanks for the super
chat yes i agree i thought that opening
scene was actually really really cool i
was really excited when i first watched
it
so uh
i really really liked it some people are
saying vince vincent kaha kais kajes
um
get netflix show vibes
which i guess yeah because i mean it
just shows like disney plus show vibes
um
you know i i think i'm a little mixed on
this i think it could go in um
i think it could go in a really good
direction
but i also think that like
depending on
the direction they said to go with it
like it could be bad it could be good
like i
it really depends and there's gonna be
six episodes guys six episodes uh yeah
robert pearson yeah you know i think she
might be madam mask i know she's not in
the comics i know she just kind of like
directs her in the comics i think they
might retcon her here to be madame mask
so
i don't know chris you think elena's
popping up in this or do you think it's
a different project or if she didn't it
could be for a different project but
i mean possibly but how much more is
hawkeye going to be involved in moving
forward
um kate bishop's going to be maybe she
goes on to be kate bishop's newman tour
well she was sending elena to kill
hawkeye though like specifically
right yeah but
she's going to figure out the truth
right because he's going to sit down and
tell her what really happened right i
mean
she's going to figure it out she's not
going to kill akka
well i realized that but you're asking
if she's going to show up in the show i
feel like the only reason you would
tease it is for her to show up in the
show
i don't know
that's what i'm saying like what other
projects moving forward uh thunderbolt
stark avengers i don't know what he's
going to be involved in but
they can have him and be
it and like really quick
or they could or they could have her try
to do something
and somebody else tells her it's like
why are you trying to kill you know what
i mean like something like fury could
intercept her or something like that
like you never just you never know it
would make sense that fury would
intercept her because of his
relationship with natasha
yeah
i think a lot of people are hoping for
it and i think people would be a little
disappointed if it didn't happen
oh yeah for sure um
be
not a big like screw you but
oh what the heck
yeah like why did you yeah what
happened so how would you feel a
daredevil show with this kind of tone my
opinion it wouldn't live up to netflix
show uh i mean we're only two episodes
in
but yeah the
netflix daredevil show is on a different
level i would agree with you and thank
you for that super chat hi
i am dirks
appreciate that
appreciate it appreciate it appreciate
it
um
yeah i mean
guys
what do you think i mean it's it seems
to be
pretty
i'm seeing some highs to nine to see
we've got two out of tens ten out of
tens two out of tens ten six point five
eight point five i i i really just think
it's gonna depend on how much you like
hawkeye and kate bishop
and how much
you
accept that this is a
um
toned down
down to earth
show
right right eternals
that's the problem right wand vision
loki
you know it's like huge loki to me was
just the best of them i loved loki such
a good
show like that
that was a great show
and
to me this doesn't really compare to it
but i have to look at it i have you have
to look at it differently because it's
not the same show like it's just not the
same show right
uh it's different characters they're
about different things this one's you
know more lighthearted which i cannot
like i can appreciate like the like the
movie red notice like how we talked
about i love red notice you know why
because it's a simple movie it's
designed to entertain it's funny it's a
little bit unpredictable but it doesn't
have an agenda you don't have to think
about much you sit back and enjoy it
right not everything has to be so deep
and connected and this is just kind of
one of those shows that's that's just
about this guy trying to get back to his
family and has to deal with this little
kid who also like looks up to him and
everything you know it's just
i take that for what it is
and that's what that's all we can do is
take the show for what it is we can't
compare it to end game because it's like
yeah
like that whatever you know what i mean
right and that's where marvel starts
seeing all these crazy
just
split ends almost with all the direction
that's going in
and i think fans have this caliber of
like well spider-man no way home has all
this and eternals was this and
so it's like
it's up to the fans to take a second
back up and say hey here's a hawkeye
appreciation post let's enjoy it
okay yeah and that does take some
perspective
it does and you know i talked to
executive producer trenton tran and i'm
like hey
why is now the time and she's like you
know iron man got his shot his movies
captain america got his luck would have
got her movie you know
and it's time for hawkeye you know thor
got his movies hulk can't have his own
solo movies you know because of the
rights but he got the movie with thor
clint's never had anything to himself
he's appeared in other films and now
it's time to give him his respect and i
think a lot of people are really gonna
like that and enjoy that and i think
some people are gonna go well it's
boring because it's hot guy like it's
just it depends on
like i
when i heard about the hawkeye show i
was actually more excited for hawkeye to
finally have his own spotlight then i
was to actually watch the show if that
makes sense
right i was like
sorry go ahead no i was just like oh
that's really cool hawkeye's finally
getting his own show i don't know if i
like it
but i'm excited that he's finally
getting his own show
i i think it's interesting how they've
already addressed that because it's
an ongoing meme like oh there's hawkeye
no no powers nobody cares about him he's
a joke and i get he's some people's
favorite hero and there's no disrespect
there
but kate bishop was like your problems
with your branding he's like i don't
care i don't care about halloween
costumes or
dolls and that's a direct
statement to us as fans and that's who
hot guy is as a superhero and as a
character is he doesn't actually care
about that stuff but does he care
i mean
people still kind of recognized who we
were people were giving him free food
and taking pictures and he didn't seem
to really want any of it
i think he just wants to live a normal
life now he doesn't want to be branded
off as some tony stark or captain
america
but does he not like it's one of those
things where it's like it's defense
mechanism to where it's like
i'm not getting the attention so i say i
don't want it
all right i think so maybe but i just
feel like the character of hawkeye has
never been one yeah and i would and i
would say that yeah like you said like
he is the guy with the family and
everything he just wants to get back to
his family for christmas so i think
probably a part of him is like well you
know
i'm i was right next to iron man and all
you know what i mean like i was there i
put the air to loki's head but at the
same time he's like but i don't it's
like i don't care
right it's like
i don't know
it's kind of like how i feel like with
my instagram and my twitter like
sometimes i'm like yeah i want like
instagram followers and then sometimes
i'm like i don't care like
like youtube's what i do
but you could follow me on instagram if
you guys want cosmic warren go do it
uh dj wavy d welcome back falcon had a
better first cause first couple episodes
than this in my opinion i would agree
with you
but i actually think
the first two episodes of [ __ ] one
soldier were the best two and then it
didn't do so good after
that i like the fact number soldier one
i don't wanna
mix that up but yeah we'll have to see
we'll have to see where this goes i'm
hoping echo is a really cool character
i'm hoping yolina shows up and i'm
hoping kingpin is behind everything even
if it's not like he has a really big
part in the show like the very last
episode's like by the way it's kingpin
you know like
um
uh isaac hey thanks for super chat yeah
i mean i'm i'm excited to see echo in
the next episode i'm excited for her
story um you know oh also kingpin is
supposed to be in the echo series that's
a big big report right now same with
matt murdock right because that whole
story right there
and that kind of fits into the hawkeye a
little bit with the whole auction
because that's like an auction that they
did in matriport in the matt fraction
run
they auctioned a
videotape of hawkeye assassinating
somebody because he was sanctioned by
shield which means extinction to buy
the u.s government so there's a big deal
so it's like a lot of matt fraction is
running this
and
uh
in that auction in the comics um
kingpin's there right now obviously it
wasn't here in this auction but a lot of
things kind of point to
kingpin but i don't wanna i don't wanna
start a mephisto but i am probably gonna
say something like yep he's coming so
we'll see
no
let's see
makes a little more sense either i mean
mephisto made so much sense too though
that's that's true
like it
would have worked just fine and it
doesn't matter that they didn't go that
direction it wasn't really a huge
disappointment it was more of a surprise
but that's how we are here with king
ping now it's like well according to the
comics and you have echo and her
storyline with kingpin and now we're
hearing about daredevil
it all lines up and makes sense so it's
almost like this has to be what they're
doing
so then when they don't we're like
well
you fooled me
yeah i think uh
i really want to say kingpin's behind
all this because i really feel like he
is i that doesn't necessarily mean that
he's going to play a big part or any
part in the show it could literally
be a post-credit scene or we could watch
echo and then discover that it was him
behind everything right because right
because feige mentioned again in the
hawkeye press conference
somebody asked like oh you know this is
in new york and spider-man's in new york
and bruce banner's in new york like all
these people in new york how do you deal
with like deciding whether they're going
to interact with each other and he was
pretty straightforward about it like we
focus on the characters who the show's
about
which is why one of vision was
wanda and vision and then the bad guy
which was also vision and then
uh i got the hardness right so falcon
the winter soldier we thought yes matcha
poor mutants but it's like nope it's
about the fact of the soldier and the
bad guy you know what happened with
these disney plushies right
uh jordan lane good question and thank
you for the super chat what's the
reasoning behind the watch i have the
same thought maybe it's tony's watch
maybe it's a piece of stark tech
um because it was found on the avengers
compound like the tag said it was uh
this one though i'm not i'm not really
i don't have an answer that i'm leaning
more towards i think it tony stark would
be my coolest bet is what i would say
like my coolest one because
other than that whose watch would it be
you know nick fury's or you know
whatever maybe have some secret launch
codes in it or something like that
pocket right exactly i i do think it um
i didn't think it could have been like
tony's old watch or something like that
so but guys we have to do a breakdown
we got lots of work to do so
this is great to be back in the streams
again i think it was a decent start to
the show i'm hoping
that
it uh ramps up and i think it's going to
with echo and
because i don't think she's the bad guy
of the show so
i'm thinking
luna shows up kingpin shows up something
i think it's going to ramp up a bit uh
ben lacy thanks for the super chat
warren you're the best hey i appreciate
that person do you think the actors lose
the same men are showing up and going
home uh yeah yeah i do uh like thomas
hayden church
and i don't know i can't remember uh liz
reiffen it it r rizz
i i can't pronounce his name ever uh
yeah i i do think they're they're gonna
show up i do
i do um november super chats guys
because we're going to stream i don't
want to miss any super chats but i
appreciate all the comments all the
super chats everybody watching in the
background um
and yeah madam madam mask
probably is going to be someone of the
main villain and it's going to be
eleanor right she's not mad at mass in
the comics but uh
you know
they're probably retconned that so
for those who liked it i'm glad for
those who didn't
uh hopefully it gets better there is
still time
isaac age think of super chat uh i'm not
even sure i'm going to the no way home
premiere because it's a whole it's sony
it's not disney or marvel they're not in
charge at all and i don't have an invite
yet so i don't even know if i'm going
but uh
enter the giveaway
all right all right
we have a giveaway
subscribe to my channel and chris's
channel the links are in the chat right
now
i'm giving away this cool thing where is
it yeah
cool thing
spider-man this is a cool thing
it's pretty cool it's on like a taxi top
subscribe to
chris's channel
mine leave some comments in our recent
videos that's how we are going to choose
so
we are out guys we love you all
thank you for joining us on these live
streams we'll be back at it again next
week and expect my breakdown pretty soon
i'll see you next time
bye woof
thank you